edouard delépine est né le 11 janvier
1932 à fort de france il sera professeur
d'histoire géographie au lycée
schoelcher mais aussi à l'université des
antilles et de la guyane
membre du parti communiste français puis
du parti communiste martiniquais de 1945
à 1971
il en sera exclu à cause de ses idées
indépendantistes
en 1972 il est l'un des membres
fondateurs du gr est le groupe
révolution socialiste
peu à peu il rompt avec l'idéologie
communiste et le courant indépendantiste
edouard delépine adhère alors au parti
progressiste martiniquais en octobre
1982 c'est au sein de ce parti qu'il
sera successivement conseiller régional
conseiller général puis élu maire de la
ville du robert de 1989 à 1997
un temps il sera inquiété dans la sphère
dédiée au métal
robert mais l'homme est aussi écrivain
il laisse de nombreux ouvrages sur
l'histoire et la vie politique de la
martinique dans l'un de ses derniers
ouvrages publiés en 2017
il recense tous les discours d'aimé
césaire edouard delépine fut
véritablement au coeur de l'histoire
politique du parti progressiste
martiniquais et de la martinique